CLAP
👏 We did it guys 👏 *CLAP*
👏 WE DID IT 👏*CLAP*
WE killed the meme.
Bye bye, Johnny.  👋 Bye bye 👋
Last week I reviewed
Johnny Johnny meme and lo and behold..
I gave it a zero.
And they deleted the video.
They scared. They know, they know
THEY KNOW THE PAIN
You don't mess with meme review.
[High pitched 9 year old voice] No one messes with meme review, my man...
Papa and PewDiePie are the same person?
.........................
<DIES ON THE INSIDE>
A lot of new memes this week, thank you!
Finally!!!!!
Elon Musk went on Joe Rogan podcast and smoked uh...
Something something...
Pretty good memes out of that pretty good meme out of that.
Yes. That's that right, we don't have time (monetization) however..
Thank you though, Elon.
In the polygon article about Johnny Johnny..
Polygon: How long do you think Johnny Johnny will be a meme?
Dolan dark...?
Apparently Dolan dark replied to Polygon.
You don't talk to the enemy,
You lil ducking schmuckling puckling
All right, don't make me
<EH>
I can finish you off
<CHOP>
THAT easy <A$$KICK>
<DOLAN TRIGGERS A$$BOMB>
<EXPLOSIVE DUCK DIARRHEA>
Dolan: Well, if the other short-lived memes from 2018 are anything to go by I would give it another week tops.
YOU'RE RIGHT!!
Leon, creator behind cartoon <demonetized> :
"The lifespan of memes can be unpredictable at times"
"Most of them make it less than two months."
How about two days? How about that
(pewds giggles)
Hey, hey, it's Polygon Vox media. We want to hear your opinion about news.
Just don't reply..
Okay?
...WTF?.....
Pathetic
Memes are so cringy...
It's just, it's just, it just hit me.
What are we doing here?
<Just to suffer?>
Are we all so desperate to just try and fit in
Just that we all have to laugh at the same jokes
and the more obscure they are, the more part of a select group you feel like you are..
But in reality..
He's just an idiot laughing at something that
really isn't that funny.
THANOS CAR!!!!
W..T..F!!!!!!! NANI????
<FAKE FORCED SKRATTAR>
<CUE SITCOM LAUGHTRACK>
Someone spotted Thanos car everybody and the internet just went...
*mind BLOWN*
Thanos Car
*clap* *clap*
Thanos Car... *clap*
if you're, if you invested in Thanos memes, for the love of God.. sell now, ok? the bubble has burst. Officially.
What is this?
How many layers of irony do we need for this meme?
Please just stop.
Of course since Thanos car became a meme, it has to trip over to any other car meme
Here we have Thanos car in the movie "Cars".
Here we have: End world, hunger, end world poverty.
THANOS CAR
wheres the: "This car can fit so many Thanos in it."
Hahahahaha. This is brilliant
But I like Thanos car
There it is, there it is, THANOS CAR, THANOS CAR
(SLAPS $399 CHAIR)
THANOS CAR!
<EXPLOSION>
No, Thanos car for Mario kart
oh, that's epic
<FORCED LAUGH>
OH MY GOD THAT IS FUNNY
You know when Adam Sandler is making fun of you. That's how you know, you're at the bottom
Okay, just stop it, please for the love of God. Stop the Thanos memes. When did the Marvel movie came out?
Why does all the things I hate become the most popular..
Fortnite.
Thanos
T series.
Thanos cat. Okay, just stop
Just cuz it's purple does not mean it's Thanos. Okay. Just get that in your heads
👏
👏 Giving this meme a three everybody
Thanos car gets a three.
That's three more than it deserves (true)
Meme review
YouTube's show. moving on.
The let me guess meme that we reviewed last week has ah.. it sort of took off
honey..
Let me guess..
You're home?
Not your home.
Yes
It is now.
god damn it
Oh my god, it amazes me and upsets me at the exact same time and it leaves me in this conflicted state, okay
Let me guess
your home
It was
And it was beautiful
Let me guess.... Home?
Yes.
Oh my god, god damn it. That was just pissing me off.
Let me guess your car.
Yes, it is.
And here's my Hot Wheel
STAAAPH
let me guess, B7
you sunk my battleship.
Hooray <CHUCKLE>
I don't hate this meme. I don't cuz it's - it's [puberty hits pewds] kind of those memes that fills your day
You see it and you get a little laugh, you know, it's gonna be gone soon
But you also know it might just rebound at some point when you expect that the least. So keep an eye out.
It's already it's already bamboozled me once, it might bamboozle you twice. I give this meme a meme correction
👏 👏
5 from 3 to 5 from last week
Meme correction everybody. Oh boy. We have a lot of memes. So let's just keep going
I was gonna go
[Pitched voice] let's just jump into it.
And then I did a high-pitch for no reason.
It's pretty awkward
MOVING ON
~AWESOME POPCORN CHICKEN~
*stop it*
~OHHHHH YEEE~
~WAIT NO NO NO
POPCORN CHICKEN:(~
ohh noo
oh god i cant look
not his...
what?
<giggle lightly>
you regret buyi...
oh it keeps going it keeps going
👏 My man 👏, Bepis..  posted this meme on 17th of June. It's just some kid
Who's using this stupid app that lets you bomb something
*BOOM*
This is so sad...
And people started making some very creative version of this
and its ah beautiful thing
It's a beautiful thing
No. WATCH OUT POPCORN CHICKEN
noooooooooooooo!!!!!!
You know anything can become a meme if popcorn chicken, you know what actually it makes perfect sense
*BOOM*
oh popcorn chicken died of ligma
damn it
It keeps spreading I thought we contained it.
join us popcorn chicken
<pewds laughs>
Have you underestimated me?!
no... no... no!!!
People sure put a lot of time to editing memes. Oh, here's the best one. This is my favorite
(2012 MEMES ARE BACK)
Can we bring back 2012 montages, please it's time.
I'm gonna categorize this meme under important, Museum worthy, save this for my grandchildren
Uh type of meme. gather around the campfire. Let's ah all watch this kind of meme. very nice.
👏 👏
its ah.. its a 2..
<laughs while dying on the inside>
I don't know what to tell you man. I don't know what to tell you. It's it's alright, it's funny
The edits are better than the meme. Okay, I'm not discriminating
👏 lest but 👏 not least 👏
believe in something even if it means sacrificing Everything.
I can tell okay. Here's the thing this AD campaign by Nike went viral because uh
Either people got very upset or they thought it was really cool.
This is not Pew News, Felix remember? okay..
Alright, I'm gonna try it
The thing that's great about this is that you can take this text and put it on literally anyone else's face any
Controversial figure or event in history that no one likes and bam
👏  You got yourself a dank meme, baby.
I feel like they did this on purpose
They know people would get upset about this meme they know it would be controversial, they don't care
It doesn't change anything. people aren't burning their Nike shoes because of this campaign. It's not pew news Okay. Alright
Ahm hey, look, it's Thanos again it's Thanos again, believe in something
even if it means sacrificing half of everything.
That's good
Gonna rate that meme
(a solid) INCONCLUSIVE
~lets see some more ones popping up~
And that's 👏 it for me 👏 for meme review hope you guys enjoyed and remember smash like
<Windows Shutdown sound>
<LINKS IN DESCRIPTION>
What in the actual F***!!!!!!!!!!
<IS IT 10 MIN YET?>
<ye i think it is>
SMASH LIKE & SUBSCRIBE ♥